did you manage to snag an NES classic
well Nintendo says that the
now-discontinued console shipped more
than 2 million units so why did it get
discontinued I'm Matt and this GameSpot
news update has at least one piece of
the puzzle speaking to time Nintendo of
America president Reggie fils-aime a
said we understand that people are
frustrated about not being able to find
the system and for that we really do
apologize but from our perspective it's
important to recognize where our future
is and the key areas that we need to
drive we've got a lot going on right now
and we don't have unlimited resources
Fiza Mae added that the NES classic was
only intended as a holiday product
noting that Nintendo extended its
lifespan for as long as it could
Nintendo has a lot on its plate at the
moment including switch supply issues
the upcoming new 2d s XL and reportedly
the SNES classic edition speaking of
that last one we'll keep you up-to-date
as more information is revealed so be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and if you're
looking for some new action on your
Nintendo switch check out our video
review of Mario Kart 8 deluxe
[Music]